Daniel: Hello and welcome.
It's June 7, 2023.
We're in ActInf Livestream 54.1,
discussing “Mathematical Foundations for
a Compositional Account of the Bayesian
Brain.”
So, welcome to the Active Inference
Institute.
We're a participatory online institute
that is communicating, learning and
practicing applied active inference.
This is a recorded and an archived
Livestream, so please provide feedback so
we can improve our work.
All backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome and we'll be following video
etiquette for live streams.
To learn more about live streams and
other projects, head over to
activimference.org.
And we're here today in active stream 54.
.1.
We are in our first discussion with the
author of the work, “Mathematical
Foundations for a Compositional Account
of the Bayesian Brain.”
Today in 54.1
we're going to say hello, then be on with
it and see where it all goes together.
So we'll begin with introductions.
I'm Daniel, I'm a researcher in
California.
Six months ago, I was quite unfamiliar
with category theory and have had quite a
fun journey with Ali and Dean and I guess
Toby via stigmergic proxy.
So, really looking forward to this
discussion.
And I'll pass to Dean
and then Ali.
Dean: Thanks, Dan.
I'm Dean.
I'm here in Calgary.
My goal in joining this group was to take
the idea, as we caught in one of the
previous slides, the idea of practicing
applied active inference.
I see the potential through category
theory of making that even more
accessible, more possible.
And so I'm really excited to have the
author with us today and maybe have a
look at what that means and I'll pass it
over to Ali.
Ali: Hello, I'm Ali, I'm an independent
researcher, premiere one, and as I said,
in zero.
I'm quite excited to be here to discuss
this magnificent dissertation with its
author in the past several months.
We did our best to understand and dissect
it as best as we could, but obviously we
have many, many questions that I'm
looking forward to discuss them with.
Daniel: So, Toby, thanks again for
joining.
Please lead us off with just any
introduction and background that's going
to set the stage, maybe how the work came
to be and that would be great.
So thanks again for joining.
Toby: Yes, great.
Well, thanks Dan and all of you guys for
hosting me and for having the courage to
read my thesis, which, as you noticed, it'
's a kind of strange mix of things.
It's kind of both the research work and,
as I noticed one of you saying in the
previous stream, it's at this kind of
frontier of knowledge and of course it
needs to be.
But I also, because this language is so
kind of unfamiliar to people and because
I think it will prove to be very useful
across the sciences, I really wanted to
make it kind of legible to people.
So for people to read the thesis, but
also, like my research and kind of
understand what I was saying effectively
how it came about was I was supposed to
be studying interactions between frontal
cortex and hippocampal circuits in the
brain.
And at the sort of time of trying to get
started with that, obviously I was kind
of interested in the free energy
principle and active inference and all of
that.
But I found that there was a lot of as I
said in the thesis and as you talked
about in the previous stream and probably
in discussions before that as well, there'
's a lot of kind of each research
group has its own language.
And these different groups, they don't
necessarily talk to each other in a way
that is kind of an efficient kind of
communication.
Each group of people is interested in
their own thing.
And one of the things I like about the
free energy principle and about active
inference is that it's this nice sort of
general framework for adaptive systems.
And so it is in itself a good place to
kind of situate an understanding of
systems like the brain and other adaptive
systems.
But of course it doesn't immediately
resolve this problem of the problem that
was for me a kind of confusion about what'
's going on in these circuits and how
should I understand what one person says
in relationship to what another person
says about this bit of the brain or this
interaction.
And so in the process of kind of trying
to understand what was going on there and
to resolve, in part, the confusion I had
about predictive coding itself and the
complexities of all of these models I was
encountering, I kind of resolved to
replace that confusion with another kind
of confusion, which is, what is all this
crazy category theory stuff?
And so you might think, okay, well, that'
's mad.
What's the point of that?
You've just made everybody's life a lot
harder.
It's kind of like that xkcd comic
[https://imgs.xkcd.com/comics/standards.
.png] where you've got all of these
different standards; and will you decide
to come together and make a new
standard?
And in fact this is happening, I think,
in like, I don't know what it was in
cellular biology, maybe.
I heard John Baez talking about this
yesterday, that they have lots of
different standards for writing down
diagrams, for describing interacting like
biological processes and the kind of
scientific community in that area has set
up a kind of mediating body to kind of
try to bring together all of these
diagram languages but they weren't really
able to do so.
So they still they instead of just coming
up with one new standard, they came up
with three new standards to try to unify
these things.
And the trouble I had or have with these
different languages or different sort of
syntaxes for talking about scientific
things is that not only are they all
different, but they're kind of all ad hoc.
.
And so the reason why I feel that there's
promise in replacing this confusion of so
many different ideas I mean, of course it'
's great to have this kind of ecosystem
of ideas about how these complicated
systems work, but it's still very ad hoc
and confusing.
And so instead of just coming up with a
new ad hoc and confusing way of
understanding these things, I was kind of
hoping to use a language which is maybe
kind of universal in some sense or it's
really capturing how we think and maybe
also how the world is actually built up.
But in particular it seems to capture
something of how we think.
And so the fundamental theorem of
category theory says that you shall know
a concept by the company it keeps to
adapt that sort of motto of, I think,
birth from linguistics, that you should
know a word by the company it keeps that'
's really like at the heart of how we
come to understand things in the world.
And I think the math that is category
theory captures that very nicely and very
precisely and at the same time enforces
the kind of discipline.
And so I know it is quite like hard going
reading this kind of research work, this
kind of introduction to all this new
stuff, but in part that's because being
disciplined is hard and doing things very
formally, precisely does require a bit of,
, well, a lot of dedication.
But that isn't to say that it's not worth
it or that these ideas even used a bit
informally somewhere down the line might
not be useful at least to sort of frame
the way we think about things.
So I hope to be some use in helping not
only sort of change the confusions that
we have, but also modulate them in a kind
of way that will be sort of useful for
people.
Daniel: Awesome.
Great starting place.
Ali or Dean, where can we begin?
How can we replace some of our prior
confusions with a new and different
confusion?
Ali, want to go first or can.
Dean: I ask a quick question to Toby?
Toby, when you were talking about when
you actually saw all of these standards,
so now you were the sort of what, you
were the hub of all of these standards.
You saw sort of all around you.
Can you maybe speak to the idea of what
you perceived or what you sensed was the
stabilizing function of those standards
but also the searching function because
of course you had gone out and realized
there were all of these different
standards at play.
I remember it in a previous professional
life of mine having to have chief
financial officers and their math sit at
the table with engineers and their math
and them talking right past one another
and making no sense to each other.
And I had to be kind of the medium
between them so that their math would
actually get a little bit sticky and they'
'd be actually able to understand and
interpret one another.
In your experience with this, how did
that play out?
Both the stabilization through the
standards and the search.
Toby: Well, I guess I should begin by
saying that this is still, like, ongoing.
.
And nor am I an expert in all of these
different standards.
But the thing that I kind of at least
noticed, right, that was that people use
languages like Bayesian inference or
reinforcement learning or dynamical
systems to talk about certain bits of the
brain that I was interested in.
And they kind of just plug all these
ideas together and it's fine.
So you want to write a paper and it's
about a particular phenomenon, and it's
great.
You maybe come up with some nice model
and you put people in MRI scanners and
the quantities in the sort of bold signal
correspond to quantities in your model.
And that's great.
It says that maybe this bit of the brain
is doing that.
I mean, we can argue about MRI at some
other time, but it doesn't really tell
you about how that little model you've
got interacts with the rest of the brain
or the rest of the world.
And so if you care about this whole
complicated thing, you want to know, how
do these parts actually talk to each
other?
And so I was just fortunate at the kind
of beginning of this, in some sense, to
be in the right place at the right time.
So I kind of knew there were these
different ingredients all being put into
these different models, and I'm only sort
of familiar with some of them, but I
could still see that they had sort of
similar structure.
And that was in part because I've been
going to some applied category theory
meetings or talks and seen that, say,
economic games, which are very closely
related to reinforcement learning, have
this kind of bi directional structure
where an agent tries to sort of
effectively, in some sense, choose.
They make an observation, and they sort
of do this kind of forward projecting
kind of thing of choosing an action at
the same time as saying, okay, well, if
supposing I take this action, what would
the payoff be?
And that's this kind of backwards facing
thing.
And then you can sort of chain that
process and think, well, if I do this in
multiple stages, like, how does the
utility I get at the end of this multi
stage process feed back to the utility I'
'm going to get, having taken just one
step right now?
And that's a similar sort of bi
directional thing to what happens in
Active, or like in well, in predictive
coding, specifically, where a little
circuit is saying, okay, well, given my
high level beliefs about what's causing
this sensory data.
I need to sort of retrofit the actual
sensory data to kind of come up with a
new belief about what those causes are.
And so that seemed to me to have the same
kind of structure.
A similar thing also happens in backdrop,
in machine learning where you have say
some neural network and you feed forward
some information through the network and
it say does a classification and then you
have some training system which says,
okay, well, actually, you had this error,
and then you need to sort of back
propagate that to update, say, some part
of the model on the basis of that.
So that also has this kind of bi
directional structure.
And it just was fortunate that at this
time people were talking a lot about
these kind of bi directional processes.
And so I was thinking about these things
at the same time I was kind of thinking
about the application of Bayesian
inference, and I kind of noticed that
they had the same structure.
And I kind of wanted to figure out what
was going on there, really sort of pin
down what it was that made this kind of
predictive coding circuit have this kind
of shape in some sense.
Because as I think you've also talked
about and as I kind of mentioned a few
minutes ago, that individual predictive
coding circuit isn't an isolated system,
right?
It's part of like this hierarchical thing.
.
And so you have one little circuit
connected to another circuit and that
whole conglomeration of circuitry is
supposed to do something quite grand, but
at the same time it's made of smaller
parts.
And one of the major confusions I had at
the beginning was, okay, so you have this
big generative model with lots and lots
of factors, and you go through it and you
try to derive the differential equations
that give you the sort of predictive
coding dynamics by saying, okay, well, we'
're going to minimize the free energy and
you have this complicated thing with lots
of sums in it and it seems like very
intimidating to try to come up with that
differential equation, even though,
actually, when you sort of look at this,
the look at the process that you're doing
is quite kind of mechanical because
effectively, you're doing the same
transformation to each factor of this
model.
And so that also hinted that there was
this kind of compositionality thing going
on in these systems.
Not only do you see that this bit of the
brain has this kind of modularity, but
you also get a sense of that modularity
in that derivation you're doing.
And so what I wanted to do was to capture
both of these things.
One is the kind of shape of the circuitry
and the other is like how to somehow save
the effort of having to kind of rederrive
everything for each different case.
And that kind of formalization of this
process corresponds to a kind of
functoriality you get when effectively
this functoriality means you preserve
compositional structure.
And so what you want to do is you want to
say, okay, well, what's the compositional
structure of the thing that the function
starts with, like the process starts with,
, and that's the compositional structure
of Bayesian inference itself.
And then you want to say, okay, well,
what's the compositional structure of the
kind of dynamical systems, which is the
thing you're trying to get to, and how do
you map from one to the other in a way
that preserves that structure?
And so that's kind of what I was doing in
this thesis, is just saying, okay, what
are the structures I need and how do I
relate them?
And it turned out that there were a lot
of details, I had to write them all down.
.
But the kind of basic idea, I hope is
quite simple.
It's just trying to say what are those
kind of the kind of individual components
like the kind of Lego blocks and how do
they connect together and how can I sort
of relate the kind of Lego blocks of one
thing with the Lego blocks of another in
a way that kind of preserves the shapes?
And so, yeah, it's kind of mammoth thing,
but the kind of fundamental idea is quite
simple.
And I think it's kind of like how when if
you're like programming a computer, you
can write in a high level language or you
can write in like low level language.
And if you wanted to, you could write in
assembly language.
And category theory is like a language
where you start with the kind of assembly
language and you build up a high level
language within the language itself in
some sense.
And so if you really want to start with
at the very beginning, like I did with
the definition of category, and then
build up to this big thing, you have to
make a lot of steps because like,
assembly language is really simple and it'
's just like single instructions that
your processor does.
And so getting all the way to something
like zoom that can do a video call is
quite complicated.
And so people don't they start with the
high level language, but the thing that
people strive for in designing high level
languages is to set them up in such a way
that the abstractions are quite nice or
sort of modular.
And so that's what I'm trying to do with
using category theory, is to kind of find
abstractions that are modular in a
similar kind of way.
And I know on the previous call, Dan, you
mentioned the kind of analogy between
Piping in this category theoretic sense
and in the programming sense, and they're
quite similar.
The category theory sense is kind of a
much sort of more general, bigger idea.
It sort of encompasses all kinds of
things.
But you could imagine somewhere down the
line having a programming language and
that people are trying to build these
things, but having a programming language
where you could express anything, you
could in category theory and I, to be
honest, find it quite intense and quite
sometimes mechanical and tedious.
How to prove that certain categorical
structure satisfies the coherence
conditions that it has to satisfy, like
lacks associativity or monoidality or
something like this.
There are a lot of diagrams you have to
check commute or something, and much of
the time that checking is quite tedious.
And someday I hope that we all have tools
that we could say, okay, well, I'm going
to spell out what my structure is, and
the tool will just check that it
satisfies all the axioms.
And so I know you guys had to wade
through a lot of that stuff in the thesis,
, but it's kind of manually necessary
right now, but in the future it might not
be.
And then we can use this high level
language in a much more kind of liberal
way, I hope.
That would be great.
Sorry, I've been waffling operators.
I'll stop there.
Daniel: Awesome.
Great.
I'll go to a question.
In the chat Mark wrote, applied category
theory and active inference have
tremendous promise.
I confess I have not yet read this
dissertation.
It would be helpful to describe a
specific engineering application for the
work.
So what do you see as proximate and and
or distal engineering applications here?
Toby: So one of the things that I hope
could be produced soon as an engineering
application is a sort of general modeling
framework for building kind of
complicated active inference systems that
might include lots of parts, lots of
agents.
Kind of like something that my colleague
Jules Hedges once in cybernetics more
generally, something like kind of
programming language, maybe, that
incorporates all of these kind of strange
cybernetic structures I mentioned earlier,
, like reinforcement learning and
backprop in machine learning and Bayesian
inference, they all have this kind of bi
directionality.
And so you should be able to have this
kind of modeling environment which allows
you to incorporate all of these things in
a kind of nice way.
But I think before we get something quite
as grand as a whole new sort of modeling
environment, I think just having tools to
help us build approximate and active
inference systems that are really nicely
compositional is one thing that I hope to
come out of this.
To be honest, I don't know very well what
the general tooling is like for this kind
of thing right now.
I know that there's SPM, I know that
there's, like, pi MDP for certain kinds
of problem, but I don't know how general
they are.
Another thing that you would get if you
have this kind of toolkit, because of the
kind of modularity of category theories,
you should be able to plug it into other
things that exist already.
So one of the things that's particularly
of interest to me at the moment is kind
of multi agent systems and sort of
building trying to understand how we
could build something like or simulate
things like something like a corporation
or some kind of some kind of society
structure where you've got lots of active
inference agents coming together to
pursue a sort of common shared goal.
How can you kind of effectively
distribute that goal sharing across
systems.
They could be like little robotic systems,
, say, or something like that, or agent
or like I don't know precisely.
I'm kind of like an abstract thinker.
But being able to kind of control or
modulate the performance of these kind of
distributed multi agent like active
inference systems might be quite a cool
thing to be able to build.
So that's kind of like maybe flavor of
the kind of thing that this tooling gives
you.
I suppose for me, this particular work
was really about trying to encourage
people to use this language to understand
things more clearly.
So, yeah, there's a lot of stuff that I
hope we can understand, or at least I can
understand more clearly.
Sure.
Daniel: Awesome.
Thank you, Ali.
Ali: Thank you.
Yes.
So in this paper by Christophe Voitowich,
are there category theoretical
explanations of physical phenomena?
He argues that category theory by itself
does not and cannot provide any
mathematical explanations for physical
phenomena.
So the idea here is that category theory
is merely a meta theory to kind of do a
kind of bookkeeping or householding of
the physical theories, and it's not a
tool to construct the mathematical theory
of physical phenomena itself.
I'm not sure I agree with this argument
entirely because in one sense, some of
the most profound, AHA, moments in the
history of science obviously results from
looking at preexisting theory or a model
from a novel angle.
And I believe category theory can provide
such novel perspectives even when looking
at some established and preexisting
models or theories.
I'm curious to know your opinion about
this.
So do you think category theory can
actually provide mathematical
explanations for either in cognitive
science, neuroscience, or even other
areas, other scientific disciplines as
well?
Toby: I think it's a subtle question.
Right now, it's probably largely the case
that the role of category theory is kind
of this I think it's like bookkeeping,
but like Clarification too bookkeeping,
if you think of it in a sort of very
general way of trying to account for the
things you're thinking about very
precisely and not sort of miss details.
Like if your books don't balance, you
kind of miss some payment or some debt.
I think that's quite a nice analogy.
But I think one of the goals of quite a
lot of people, or not maybe a fair chunk
of the community, particularly that which
comes from a sort of more abstract
mathematical side of category theory, one
of their goals is to try to recast a lot
of how we think in kind of purely
categorical language.
So one of the things that category theory
allows us to do is to kind of formalize
in some sense patterns that crop up all
over the place using the notion of
universal construction.
And the thing about universal
constructions is that you have some
little pattern.
And if you know that you can instantiate
that pattern in your category, that you
have some object which kind of captures
the essence of that pattern and you don't
need to say be able to kind of write down
all of the specifics of that object sort
of a priori, because the kind of
universality gives you a recipe for
constructing it.
It gives you it in some sort of unique
way.
And so you know that if you have this
universality, you can always access this
object.
I'm talking very generally, but because
of that, one thing that people try to do
is to try to say okay, well, we've got
these things that we're interested in in,
say, physics like the principle of least
action or the nature of spacetime or
something like that.
Can we express those things as kind of
universal constructions or, for instance,
in a completely different realm, like we
might have some process which is
something we're interested in on the
computer, like the migration of data in
databases.
Can we write that down in a way that
doesn't have any kind of ad hoc
ingredients?
It only is built from universal
constructions.
These are things that we can just write
down kind of abstract sort of axioms in
the language of category theory and that
kind of gives us the process or the
structure that we want.
This kind of line of work is often called
like synthetic something like synthetic
probability theory or synthetic physics
or synthetic topology or something like
that.
And it means you sort of start from these
kinds of very high level categorical
ideas and then you sort of end up with a
characterization of the essence of the
thing you're interested in in physics.
A simple example of this which I supply
in a kind of relatively feeble effort to
say that it's not true that category
theory doesn't give you a
characterization of things in physics.
So there is a category of, say,
topological spaces and the morphisms
between them are continuous functions.
And there's a category rather of sets.
And the morphism between the sets are
functions.
And of course, underlying every
continuous function is a plane function.
And so there is a function from the
category of topological spaces to the
category of sets which just forget the
topological structure of the spaces
because every topological space has an
underlying set of points.
So you have this forgetful functor and
this forgetful functor has two adjoins.
And one of the things the category theory
teaches you is that adjunctions give you
this universality.
So adjoin functions are characterized
uniquely by their kind of satisfaction of
this adjunction property.
So these two adjoints to this forgetful
functor one gives you what are called
discrete spaces.
So if you take a set, you can turn it
into a topological space by thinking of
all the points as little islands in this
space so there's no connectivity between
them.
And that's called a kind of discrete
space on that set.
And the other adjoin puncture gives you
what's called the indiscrete or sometimes
co discrete space where all of the points
are sort of collected into one big island,
, so they're all sort of connected
together.
So it's like a sort of fully connected
graph.
And of course that's very different from
the discrete space and it's different
from the spacetime or the space that you
live in which has a particular kind of
connectivity, like you can't walk through
walls.
And so people try to use these things,
particularly use adjunctions to
characterize things like properties of
spaces.
Another thing that comes out of a
jointness and this is something that I
can let you read about later because it'
'll take me the rest of the talk to try
to explain.
But you might be familiar from logic that
you have these quantifiers, you have
existential and universal quantifiers and
you can do things with these quantifiers
like you can sort of compose them
together.
So you get things like for all x, there
exists for Y, such that this and you can
think sometimes of these composites or
these compositions of quantifiers as like
maybe like modal operators.
Like you can sort of decompose necessity
and possibility in terms of the
compositions of logical quantifiers.
But the kind of weird thing about
quantifiers is that they too arise out of
an adjunction.
It's kind of like they are left and right
adjoints to substitution.
So if you have a proposition, you can
substitute a term intimate and the
adjoint punctures to substitution give
you the quantifiers and you can sort of
take this another step and then you can
think about like composing these adjoin
punctures and those give you the modal
operators.
And so that's something that comes just
out of category theory, but is really
sort of fundamental in sort of logic.
And we might think that there's a kind of
close relationship between physics and
computation or physics and logic, or
physics and information and information
and computation and logic.
So I think it's not quite true that there'
's nothing to be gained from thinking
about kind of traditional mathematical
things or traditional physical things.
Using category theory.
In some sense doing that really clarifies
the essence of them because it tells you
what their kind of universal properties
are and you can then instantiate those
things in different contexts.
So one of the things that you could do is
start to think about these kind of
logical structures in different contexts.
.
And that's kind of like what type theory
is all about.
And you could use it to think about the
logic of dynamical systems, or you could
use it to try to characterize, say, the
universal property even of the free
energy principle.
And that's something that I like to think
about sometimes.
How can we think about active inference
systems as trying to achieve their
goals?
Is that related to these adjunctions that
come up in sort of foundations of logic
when you look at them categorically?
And if it is, then that's quite profound
because.
It tells you that maybe the FEP does have
this kind of universality that people
want to claim it does.
So I think it is true that right now,
because it's quite early days, category
theory is kind of mostly used for
bookkeeping.
But I guess that might be because there's
quite a lot of bookkeeping to do before
we can make the most of this kind of move,
, make the most of using these kind of
universal structures and maybe one day
further in the future where people are
more familiar with this kind of language
and we have this big library of
categorical tools and our computer sort
of modeling environments and programming
languages know how to import stuff from
this category just really easily.
And so you don't have to do all this kind
of PDS manual stuff.
Maybe like in that future it'll be much
more common just to say okay, well we're
going to start to model things using
these universal properties off the bat
rather than trying to sort of retrofit
them.
Daniel: Awesome.
Thank you Toby.
Ali?
Ali: Yes.
Thank you so much for your detailed
answer and again I have a follow up
question to that.
So there's this view in philosophy of
science that views scientific theories as
not as a kind of monolithic, I mean,
phenomena or model, but rather any given
scientific theory can be viewed as a
population of models.
So some of those models are more
fundamental than the others.
Or in terms of manual delanda, there are
virtual and actual parts of any given
scientific model.
So the idea here is that the actual parts
of scientific models try to capture the
context dependent behavior of phenomena
or any physical system.
But on the other hand, the virtual or
more fundamental part of scientific
models or theories try to somehow capture
its more abstract and abstract model of
the phenomena in terms of its topological
invariance.
So do you think category theory can
provide a rigorous language to somehow
unify this view of science and to see how
exactly those context dependent part of
scientific theories fit or at least can
be compatible with the context
independent part of scientific theories
or the virtual part?
Because you see, in the context dependent
or actual models scientists usually try
to refine their models to fit the data as
close as possible or at least
approximately close enough to be useful.
But for the more fundamental parts
comprising of principles, axioms and so
on, they only try to capture the
topological terrain or the topological
invariance of the models and how models
can be compared in terms of their
singularities and topological shapes.
Toby: Yeah, that does sound very familiar.
.
I don't know this kind of work or idea in
any I haven't come across this before,
but it does sound something that be quite
amenable.
And in fact, there seems to be, at least
in my mind, some alignment between this
kind of sense of virtual that you're
talking about and this kind of
universality that I was talking about.
So you could think of a category of
models of particular kind as being
inhabited by all of those things which
satisfy these invariants.
And then you have different individual
instances of these things which would be
like the object of the category, and then
the differences between them are the
morphisms.
And the thing about morphism in the
category is that often they are the
things which preserve the structure.
In other bits of mathematics, they're
called homomorphisms, and that's where
the word morphism comes from.
And so you could think of those as ways
of comparing the models or translating
the models from one to the other, but
preserving those invariants.
That seems to me to capture some of the
idea that you were sketching.
I guess one thing which may or may not be
useful, depending on how you look at it,
that category theory gives you is it's
obviously kind of a lot more general.
And so it allows you to talk about
invariants of kinds that are more than
just more than just topological in some
sense, like functoriality is it kind of
captures the kind of invariance as well
and saying, okay, well, we preserve this
structure.
Just one way of looking at a topological
space is to take its its what's called
its nerve.
And so that takes a topological space and
turns it into a category.
And you could sort of think of the
morphisms in that category as the paths
in that space, or ways to sort of get
from one sort of part of the space to
another.
And then morphisms functions between
topological spaces considered in
categories like that, they really are
just things that preserve those
topological structures.
This language kind of seems to encompass
the kinds of things you're saying, yeah,
it would be nice.
I would love somebody to make that
connection.
Daniel: Just follow up on this and then
dean it's.
A related comment from Roman in the Chat.
.
Roman wrote, quoted you in this fractal
quote, streaming thinking about the FEP
through category theory and relation to
goals maybe allows to prove that FEP has
the universality that people claim it has.
.
And Roman asks, didn't Maxwell, Ramstead
and Dalton Sactiva Develle already kind
of prove this in the Bayesian mechanics
physics of and by belief work?
So you're talking about the role of
generalization.
What do we gain with the category
theorification of FEP beyond, for example,
, the generalizations that we've seen in
Bayesian mechanics and g theory over the
last year?
Toby: Yeah, that's a great question.
I think Maxwell and Dalton are doing a
great job formalizing the ideas of
Bayesian mechanics, but as far as I'm
aware, the job isn't done yet.
And so I haven't yet seen I have a
particular aesthetic right.
And I would like I would like to see a
really clear recipe of a way to take on
the one hand or, like, some machine that
takes in that has, like, a particular
shape that is, like, input shape.
And it takes in a dynamical system of a
particular kind and it gives me back like
the the specification of an inference
problem that that dynamical system is
solving.
I think that's what Bayesy mechanics is
saying.
It's saying, okay, well, if we have a
dynamical system that is somehow kind of
you could sort of look at it and say it
has a boundary or Markov blanket, that
you can write down its dynamics as if it
were doing free energy minimization that
is solving some inference problem.
I think that statement is true for
certain classes of dynamical systems, but
I don't think the story has been made.
The questions for me are like what are
the classes and what's the essence of
those dynamical systems?
So the result might depend on specific
technical criteria which maybe you think,
okay, well, that's kind of like a
distraction from this kind of abstract
principle which we're trying to get at.
And so it would be nice to sort of know
what the actual essence is of the problem
that allows us to do this translation.
And then there seemed to me to be
questions of other fairly technical
questions, but questions about things
like what is this boundary thing?
Like how long does it persist and what
does it mean to separate a thing off and
consider it as having a boundary?
Most of the treatments I've seen of this
idea have not been done, have not been
explained or expressed in this
compositional way.
And so they just assume you're given a
system and a boundary and then that's
kind of it.
But boundaries come in all kinds of
shapes.
Like the boundaries of the cells in my
body are kind of all like glued together
in a particular way and they form me and
I also have a boundary.
And so how do the kind of local inference
problems that are being solved by those
individual cells, given their gluing
amount to the kind of inference problem
that my whole body is solving?
And I don't think an answer to that is
anywhere near given right now.
And yet, obviously we look at systems out
in the world and they all seem to display
this property of ReEnergy minimization or
at least something that looks a lot like
it.
And so it would be nice to be able to
relate those kind of inference problems
to one another.
So I think there's still a lot to be done.
.
Just because we've kind of made some
first steps doesn't mean that we're all
of the way there.
Obviously, given my aesthetics, what I
would love to see is this kind of
abstract characterization of this
universality.
And I think there's a way of stating or
at least the structure of that universal
property using this compositional active
inference language of which the thesis is
a part.
But effectively it seems to be something
like this adjoint thing that I was
talking about earlier.
So on the one hand, you have something
like a functor that takes statistical
problems and gives you dynamical systems
that kind of solve those inference
problems.
And so that's a functor from statistical,
what I call statistical games into
dynamical systems of some kind.
But of course you have lots of dynamical
systems.
And so what this Bayesian mechanics idea
seems to be saying is that you can go the
other way as well, and maybe this mapping
in the other direction is also functional.
.
And that would be a way of characterizing
this kind of gluing together of dynamical
systems like I was talking about cells
and ending up with maybe dynamical
statistical games that also have this
kind of fluing property.
But there's still a fair amount of work
to be done even to get the basic
framework to sell out that story
precisely work that I'm trying to slowly
get on with at the moment.
But I think the ingredients to doing this
in the kind of generosity that I would
like is starting to become clear and so
hopefully we get there, but I don't think
it's sold yet.
Daniel: Awesome.
Yes.
Just so cool to see all these paths
weaving together.
Dean.
Dean: I think it's awesome, Toby, that
you in this conversation have kind of
anticaptured adjointness and common
jointness because I think that's a huge
part of your work here in reading it.
Here's my question.
I think, and I would like you to maybe
comment on this as though you were
explaining it to a very curious 15 year
old.
So on the sort of most basic level, when
I hear under sort of a common jointness
principle, the word bookkeeping, I
immediately wonder, okay, so what is the
partner, what's the thing that's being
glued to, to use your metaphor?
And so I would glue it to taking receipts,
, essentially, where you have a
stabilization of a record under
bookkeeping.
So I get that part and then the taking
receipts is the stabilization of the
change function, right?
The exchange, something that we receive,
those two things seem to kind of work
together, which then allows for
compositionality and all that other stuff.
.
But maybe I wonder if maybe you could
kind of speak to this idea that something
is presented to us and then what the
category theory does is allow us to now
start working with so where does this
fit?
Does this fit under this superordinate of
being a tool?
Or does it fit under this column directly,
, adjacent as a rule?
That's the part where I think the
adjoinness could be really helpful in
terms of maybe helping people see the
applicability and not just the
abstraction.
What's your thoughts on that?
Toby: I think David Spivak talks about
category theory as being like a kind of
accounting system, or accounting systems
plural for mathematics.
And I think he's kind of quite right then.
.
So the way I see it is when you're
keeping books, particularly if you're
sort of using like this double entry
system, you're trying to keep track of
the stuff that kind of flows into and out
of your account, your company or whatever
it is, without sort of missing some bits.
.
You see where everything goes.
And so that's how I think of this kind of
mathematical language.
You have this stuff and it's kind of like
some abstract collection of things, maybe
mathematical ideas and well, A functor
takes that stuff and does something with
it and turns it into some stuff of
another kind.
But it's like this kind of double entry
idea that when you take something out of
here, you have to put it in here and so
you have to sort of keep track of all the
details, at least all of the details that
are relevant to those two, to that flow,
I suppose.
And so when you have an injunction, you
have a way of going from one place to
another and back again without losing
track of some stuff.
It's like a little bit kind of like you'
're allowed to lose track of some stuff
but you know the stuff you've lost track
of because you don't care about it.
You might allow for some have some buffer
there, but you know how big your buffer
is, something like that.
So more precisely, like an A junction is
a way to map from one category to another
and back again in such a way that the two
mappings are kind of like ideal
approximations of the inverse of each
other and that you can sort of measure
the difference between them.
It gives you like an isomorphism between
the two sets of morphisms of some kind
and that that kind of gives you this nice
kind of structure preservation property,
this kind of bookkeeping property.
I know that there are people out there
who have used category theory to model
stock flow diagrams and so these are used
in economics to measure flows of stocks
and things like that, but they're also
used in epidemiology to model the
transmission of disease because that's
also like a flow of some stock.
You have people moving around.
And so it would be nice to sort of bring
this idea full circle and have this
mathematical language of bookkeeping
actually applied to bookkeeping.
But I don't know how that would go just
yet.
If we think of economies and corporations
as adaptive systems or if we somehow kind
of translate from flows of money to flows
of information, that there does seem to
be like an analogy between that kind of
flow and the kind of flows that we think
of in active inference explicitly.
And another thing, one of the things I
like about category theory is it allows
us to make these analogies in a precise
way and so maybe we can relate these two
things quite clearly.
It's yet to be done, but I would love to
see it.
Daniel: Awesome.
Dean smiles when his keywords are buzzed
during a response.
We'll go to another great question in the
chat from Matt N.
Matt wrote can you provide some ideas
about the next necessary steps or
milestones for categorical theory to be
effectively utilized across research and
in subsequent engineering applications?
And I'll just kind of append to that.
What do you think at the individual team
and organizational scale?
What can we do, what milestones exist to
realize some of these engineering
applications and implications that you
brought up?
Toby: Right?
So I think the main thing possibly,
unfortunately for you guys, who spent a
lot of time reading the details that I
wrote, is to kind of have this community
develop to a stage where the tools that I
mentioned that allow us to kind of use
these category theoretic concepts
fluently without having to know all of
those boring and complicated details, to
develop those to a stage where people are
actually able to use them without being
kind of like mathematicians or category
theory domain experts.
So this is, I think, starting to happen.
I guess as a result of the kind of needs
of the Pandemic, people have developed
these tools for Epidemiology.
I mentioned this stock flows stuff and I
think you can probably there's like some
I can't remember what it's called,
unfortunately now.
So in the Julia programming language
there's this great framework to use for
kind of building systems using category
theory concepts.
But of course this doesn't satisfy the
property of not having to be a category
theory domain expert.
Yet on top of that, people have built
using compositional ideas about dynamics,
frameworks for building compositional,
dynamical systems and compositional
models for things like Epidemiology and
stuff like that.
And hopefully you will get there also
with statistical modeling and active
inference and all that stuff.
But once you've got that kind of lower
level library, people can start to build
user interfaces on top of it.
And that's the thing that's starting to
happen now with the stock flow stuff.
And I think that people involved in that
project, they know that there's one kind
of major proprietary tool for doing this
kind of modeling which is used for it's
used by lots of different organizations.
For instance, it was used by governments
for modeling during the Pandemic.
But it's not very collaborative, it's not
compositional.
So if you have this huge model, it's very
hard to deal with, to modulate just some
small part of it.
And so these people, as I say, it's very
unfortunate.
I can't remember all their names or the
name of the software, but they're
building this tool which allows you to
build out these models just using this
interface.
But it's built out of this compositional
stuff and so it has a lot of the nice
properties that come out of it.
And of course, if you want, you can sort
of delve under the hood and understand
actually how it works and connect it to
all this other stuff and maybe down the
line when we've got really advanced tools
that that will kind of be able to be done
for free and some nice user interface.
But I think so if people want to make the
most of this, they could sort of get
involved with that kind of effort or at
least they could sort of get familiar
with the kind of basic ideas of
categorical modeling or compositional
thinking, as I like to say these days.
But I also don't want to prescribe to
people they have to know what like a
monad is and all that stuff because, you
know, there are it is technical, it has
to be technical because it's about
technical stuff.
But I mean, it's also trying to be
ergonomic and if that's your thing, you
can try to help make it more so.
Daniel: Awesome Dean.
Dean: No, I'm waiting because there's a
part of the paper that the belief
updating and the fuzzy of distributions
and stuff.
I'm going to want to talk about that
later, but I'm done for now.
Daniel: All right, I'll go to a question
submitted by Jr also who created the
syllabus.
So thanks again Jr, for that amazing work.
.
So Jr.
Wrote in compositional active Inference
from May 17, 2021.
Toby said I'm with Valeria on this.
I think we need to seek AI alignment for
the artificial intelligences that we
already have things like corporations and
social systems and we should be
concentrating on those right now.
Could you speak more about how you
envision this kind of application?
This is especially interesting in light
of what we spoke about in the 54.0
regarding sensor fusion and consensus.
What might this mean for corporations and
social systems?
Toby, do you mean that this between
humans and things kind of like artificial
intelligences or machines and artificial
intelligences in the context of companies
and societies?
Toby: Yeah, that's a great question and I
think Jr has done a great job with the
syllabus, which I also had a look at.
Yeah, I think it's a good list of
material and concepts to sort of get to
grips with, but as per yeah, AI alignment,
, it's a very vexed issue.
Of course, I put this to people who are
involved in the AI safety community and
some of them say, oh well, we concentrate
on machine intelligent rather than
corporations because there's like no hope
for making corporations safe.
Like it's too late, they're already out
there so we can't fix that.
Which is obviously a very sort of
defeatist attitude, but maybe it's right
to concentrate on a matter where they
think that they can actually have an
influence.
But I do nonetheless still think that
corporations are like super intelligences.
.
They've been made out of code, but the
code isn't a traditional computer
programming language.
It's the legal programming language that
makes up their contracts.
But those contracts determine how they
operate and are executed on a thing,
which is a bit like a computer, like the
legal system.
You go in a court, it processes the
contract and it explains what the outcome
is going to be.
It's like a computer, but it's like made
up of people and they have goals and
desires and they take actions and they
receive information from the world.
And so, yeah, they're a lot like, well,
AI systems.
But it's nice because we can pun on AI
and have it mean both artificial
intelligence and active inference.
That's like a long preamble.
One of the things that at least as far as
I know right now, the active inference
literature doesn't talk an awful lot
about, at least not very precisely, is
this notion of sense of fusion.
So you can have like two say you have
like two yeah.
So if you think about the brain, again,
you've got two little neural circuits
next to each other and they're making
predictions about two visual receptive
fields.
But those visual receptive fields, they
kind of often overlap.
And so what we might want a system like
the brain to do is to be able to kind of
glue the two inferences that those
circuits make together over this overlap
so that you get this unitary perception.
We don't just see a bunch of independent
patches of the world.
We see this kind of glued together thing,
even though the way it's been inferred is
through lots of individual systems next
to one another.
And so it's quite clear how to put two
things next to each other mathematically.
.
You just take their sort of product, then
you just do them side by side.
But when you want them to sort of glue
together in this way, you might encounter
some problems.
Like you might have one make one
inference and one make another inference.
.
And so you get like a disagreement and
then you need to start to say, okay, well,
, what's going on there?
What is the nature of this disagreement?
Is it something that can be resolved by,
say, passing some messages between the
two systems?
Or do we need to just ignore some of the
data?
Or is there fundamentally some paradox
which means that we can't resolve this
disagreement?
And so in mathematics, there's a lot of
theory that's been done about precisely
this question in topology in a kind of
abstract way related to the field of what'
's called cohomology, which is all about
measuring obstructions to doing this kind
of gluing thing.
And sort of in this world of applied
topology, people talk about algorithms
for resolving disagreements and things
like that, and they often have the flavor
of diffusion.
You can sort of think of diffusion as
like smoothing out disagreements because
you're just sort of like letting stuff
propagate something.
There maybe could be said about how these
diffusion models work in generative AI,
but I haven't really thought about that.
And so maybe there's something to be done
for political systems or corporations.
Like, maybe we can look at how the
mathematics says we can resolve these
disagreements and implement better
processes in our organizations that are
inspired by those algorithms or kind of
universal properties and maybe that'll
make the world a kind of more harmonious
place.
Or maybe it will just help us build
systems in the future which resolve
disagreements better.
And this is one of the reasons why I was
talking about multi agent systems before.
.
I know this is a thing that sometimes
people think about in the context of
blockchain systems and things like that,
which are actually actively composed of
lots of different participants.
But I don't know yet how it might all pan
out.
I mean, ultimately the question of
alignment is really about do the goals of
this other system disagree with my
goals?
And if the other system has more power
than you, then ultimately there's
probably not much you can do about it,
regardless of whether there exists some
algorithm that might help you smooth it
out.
So I hope at least that by looking at how
the mathematics says, we can optimally
resolve disagreements or smooth them out
or patch things together or build kind of
multi agent system that will help us
build things in the future in such a way
that we don't get to a situation where
the systems we're working with are
actually aligned against us.
Say.
But obviously we can't really guarantee
it.
We actually have to sort of do some work.
.
But it's nice that at least the framework
of active inference allows us to talk
about that at least, right?
So we can say like, oh, I have these
beliefs about the world and this other
agent has these beliefs about the world
and then we can express these beliefs in
a mathematical framework which is
amenable to using these tools from
cohomology and applied topology to be
able to start to make use of that work
that's already been done.
It's to me not so clear how you would do
that if you're not working in this active
inference world and you're working, say,
with just reinforcement learning.
I know there are similar questions about
how to kind of glue together preference
functions in economics.
And I think for me, the simplest way to
kind of understand those questions is to
kind of turn those preference functions
into distributions over states and then
use this kind of sort of more active
inference language to think about it.
So, yeah, again, we're just at the start
of this process, but it sounds like we
should be able to make use of this wealth
of tooling which has been developed in
other fields.
Because we're putting this into this kind
of modular categorical language, we
should be able to kind of put these two
modules together and make make the most
of them.
Daniel: Thanks.
I'm going to go to a different sort of
question here.
I'm going to play dissertation roulette
but I kind of know where I'm going to go
and I'm going to skip to a diagram.
It's a diagram at the end of chapter six,
and it looks like this.
So what do we see here?
What happens in this graphical
arrangement?
It doesn't have to be ultra specific
about defining every variable, but is
what matters here that's apology or the
geometry?
Is it an arbitrary visual layout, but you'
're conveying something about the
connectivity?
Or is it read from left to right?
Or is there a certain way to understand
or just approach these diagrams which in
slightly smaller forms or larger forms we
see peppered throughout category theory
and your dissertation?
Toby: Okay.
Yeah.
So here what I'm trying to do is say that
if you have a hierarchical predictive
coding system, if you take the form of
two parts that are sort of plugged into
one another and this is the the G.
And the H, if you, like, do predictive
coding on G and you sort of plug that
into H, and then you do predictive coding
on H with that input.
It's the same thing as doing predictive
coding directly on the two parts as if
they were one thing at the start.
So what I mean is, if you have here we've
got like a hierarchical system.
Again, the parts of the hierarchy are G
and H.
And we could do two things.
We could either apply predictive coding
to the two parts and then glue those
predictive coding systems together, or we
could glue like the G and H together and
then apply predictive coding to GH the
Glued system.
And what this bit of this result is
saying is if you do those two processes,
you get the same dynamical system.
And that's saying that this predictive
coding thing, at least with this sort of
Laplacian scheme, is functional.
So in this diagram, it is read from left
to right.
I mean, some sense you can orient these
diagrams however you want as long as you'
're clear about how the information flows.
.
And if I remember rightly, what we've got
is we've got some like yes, we've got X
and Y.
We've got one system which is predicting
X and one system which is predicting Y.
And I'm not totally sure what P and Q are,
, but I guess they relate to X and Y.
And you've got some stuff that's coming
into the predictive coding system, h of G
and some other stuff which is coming in
and going to H of H.
And these give you like updated states.
So in predictive coding with this LaPlace
algorithm, what happens is that you get
this new observation that comes in and
you look at the error between that
observation and your prediction and you
update your prediction according to the
sort of direction that error points you
in.
And so that's what these HG and HH
systems are doing.
But because it's a hierarchical system,
this second layer, which this.
Second layer requires you to take in the
prediction of the first layer.
So if you sort of follow in the flow of
information, HH takes in inputs from
Gamma.
Gamma is the kind of the predictive
channel, the predictive part of G.
And so that feeds into H.
And the update of G, which is a sort of
layer above H, requires this newly
updated belief from H.
Right?
So that's going sort of up in the causal
hierarchy.
And so if you sort of follow the flow in
as well into this G update function at
the top H of G, you see that it gets an
input from this sigma function.
And that's the new belief emitted by the
H system.
In this part of the proof, at least that
was the notation I used.
And so this is just saying, if you do
predictive coding on these two bits, it
has this structure which is you do the
forwards pass down through the system G
and then H, and that gives you a
prediction at the kind of lowest level.
And then you take your observation, which
is, I think, thing you get in here in Z.
Yeah, that's what Z is.
It goes into H.
You get an updated belief that comes out
in the form of the sigma and then gets
passed to the first level of the
hierarchy, which is used to give you the
highest level of belief.
Great.
Daniel: Well, it's awesome because in so
many papers we see what I guess people
expect and prefer, which is you should be
able to make a nested model here and have
communicating agents here and do
sophisticated affective inference in this
way.
And it's like we're already playing with
the Legos in a sense, and talking about
it like it's a total play shop.
So to understand in a way that is worthy
of dissertation research, some of that
substrate, it's basic Lego research.
And how do you know when you're working,
you describe this as a result?
How do we know?
I mean, can I just draw a line from here
to here?
Or can I just make a D and just have D
connect to Gamma?
What rules do you keep a guidebook or
recipe on the table?
What rules help us know what edges and
shapes you can even draw?
And when you describe the manual checking,
, are you looking for what right?
Toby: Yeah, this is a good question.
It is like a language.
So it has a syntax.
And that syntax is like the I mean, it's
like the grammar, right?
And it tells you what things make sense
to say and so you only say those things.
Daniel: Don't we all?
Don't we all?
Toby: No, but that but it's, it's it's
that's what I am laughing because often
you want to like play with the grammar,
right?
And so sometimes you're like, oh, it
feels like I'm not allowed to draw this
thing.
I'm not allowed to connect this box to
this other box in this way, but I really
want to do that, and that's not a bad
thing.
You shouldn't do it in that diagram where
it doesn't make sense, but you should
take that feeling and reflect on it and
say, but that's saying that maybe this
diagram syntax is missing something
important.
And then you should trust your intuitions
there and say, okay, well, actually, what
do I need to do to this diagram language
to make it allow me to do that move that
I wanted to do to draw that thing I
wanted to draw?
And so that suggests that you're walking
through, like, a valley, and you can see
there's a hill over here, and there's
something peeking out over it.
And you're like, actually, there's
something over there I need to be able to
see.
And so you have to move over towards a
different place to be able to get to that
place.
And so you should do that right then.
That's fine.
But the reason why I said at the
beginning, don't just draw it in your
diagram is because then that means your
diagram doesn't mean anything, and that's
worse.
So this is part of the reason that it
actually requires using this kind of
mathematical formalism.
Really, using mathematics generally
requires this discipline because you don'
't want to say things that don't make
sense.
If you have an intuition, you should do
it justice and treat it seriously.
And you probably get more out of it by
figuring out what's missing.
So with this particular kind of string
diagram language, you can't just get used
to reading them right?
So you know that these little black dots
mean copy some information.
So if you see the first one or like, the
second one on Y, you go from Y, you go
into this copier and you just send the
information to both of those outputs.
If you read like Bob Cooker's work or say,
, his book on his book Picturing Quantum
Processes, which is all about quantum
theory, using this string diagram
language, there are lots of different
rules for stuff you can do with these
languages.
Like you have colored spiders, he calls
them, which are like colored versions of
these black dots.
And there are things you're allowed to do.
.
Like if you have two spiders next to each
other that are the same color, you can
sort of merge them to be a spider with as
many legs as the two of them.
And if they don't have the same color,
then you can sort of split them apart.
And those kinds of moves are like part of
the syntax of this language, but it's a
human language.
And so people developed it, and they
realized that they could do some things,
and they realized that they couldn't do
others.
And they tried to make the rules of the
game match the things they wanted to do,
and they ended up with this language
which is now used a lot in quantum
computing because it's a very sort of
natural language for that problem.
So as to how do you know what kinds of
things to draw?
Well, here, like I was trying to prove
functionality, which is a sort of general
property.
And it says the thing it says, in an
abstract way, the thing that I started by
saying, which is there I wanted H of G h
to be the same as H.
Yeah.
See here, if you see this line, the
update map of the composite system, you
see I've got HH after HG.
Well, I want that to be the same as H
just applied to H after G.
And so that says, okay, well, I want
these two things to be equal.
And so what I do is I draw the two
diagrams for the two parts, and you draw
them out, and first of all, they don't
look equal.
And you're like, oh, that's annoying.
But then you stare at it for a bit and
you reflect on the kind of moves that you'
're allowed to make.
You think, well, okay, maybe I can apply
this move, and it makes the diagrams look
a bit more similar, and eventually you
make the diagrams look the same.
You've only used rules that you're
allowed to use.
I see.
Sort of skimming through to see if it
looks like that directly in the thesis,
but effectively, that's what's going on.
It's just that the rules are a little bit
abstract, though.
That being said, I know that Pavel
Sobachinsky, who's researcher in category
theory at Tallinn, he's got a project
with a colleague of his to build a mobile
game, which is all about making string
diagrams equal in this way.
And so the idea is that in this game, you
have pictures like this, and you've got
certain moves you can do to manipulate
the pictures.
And the sort of aim of the game is to
transform one starting picture into the
sort of goal picture just by applying
these moves.
And as you go through the game, the kind
of moves you can do become more
complicated.
But it's I mean, it's the same kind of
process.
I'm not sure the game is at the stage now
where you're allowed to do this human
creative thing and think, actually, I
want to make there be a new kind of move,
or change the diagrams or add in a color
here or something that's a really human
thing and designed to say you shouldn't
do that.
But I'm just trying to advocate for doing
that in a way which is also rigorous.
Daniel: Awesome.
Yes, to speak fluently the syntax and the
grammar, whether we're talking about
natural human language or we're talking
about the active inference ontology, we
want the syntax to be unobtrusive, if not
compressient, so that we can actually
convey the semantics, because that's the
real information flow.
The syntax is within the Shannon signal
entropy space.
And then in live stream 17 and 40 and the
physics as information processing with
Chris Fields where we've been exploring
these semantic Bayesian information flows
that must, out of necessity, to be
enriched beyond the syntax, have to
include an individual or shared context
that flow necessitates the proper syntax.
.
And so it's just part of the learning.
And so it's exciting to see that there's
games and work like yours and others to
help because if we could play with those
Legos and get the instantaneous feedback
just like learning with a language tutor
of like, no, these two pieces, they don't
fit together.
And then we kind of would actively infer
patterns, make our own rules and
understandings, but there would be
certain compositionality of the system
itself.
And so it's interesting to think of like
you described it as a natural language.
It is technical and naturally arising.
And our natural language, without going
too much into the superior wharf and
everything like that, it reflects the
kind of subject, object, verb structure
that we often want to convey.
This is a natural language for science.
It conveys what we want to convey.
And so being able to do that in a way
that is both disciplined and rigorous,
also enabling low cognitive overhead
fluency for some individuals today, but
for more tomorrow, that's just extremely
powerful.
And the fact that it has such a beautiful
and intuitive way to graphically
represent it is very promising because
that may tap us into a more holistic
understanding and a visual field or a
felt sense understanding that just
looking at this and someone says, wait,
this is what we learn in active inference.
.
It's like, well, no, that's not even the
tip of the iceberg.
There's so much more to it.
And it's not only this and all of that,
but it's one of the pieces that at this
moment in time, in our sort of early
calculator phase or Abacus phase, almost,
it's one of those things that we're
tackling, but it's the wave that we're
riding.
And I just can't wait until there's more
accessibility and the learning pathways
and the playgrounds to use all this.
Toby: Yeah, I mean, I totally agree with
all of that.
And I think it was nice to see the gr in
this syllabus that included references to
Eugenia Cheng's work because she's done a
lot of great work to kind of make
mathematics more accessible in this way.
She had an article in the Guardian, like,
in the last week or so, even talking
about mathematics education and how it
often, like, scares people because they'
're taught to.
Like, you just apply algorithms in this
kind of blind way to do, like,
multiplication or calculus or whatever
and not really play with the concepts in
the way that I was trying to say.
Okay, well, you're drawing these diagrams
and you want to play with them.
And it would be nice to see mathematics
education take this kind of more playful
route to start with.
One of the things that Eugenia says in
this article is that unfortunately, that
would make things kind of slower because
you just want people to muck around.
You don't want people just to be able to
churn out this kind of computation.
But in this future where our
computational tools are so powerful,
maybe we don't all need to be perfect
integrators or like derivators and be
able to multiply numbers quickly.
And some people like doing long division,
but I don't even remember how to do long
division.
Why would I?
It's silly to kind of drill that into
children.
So there have been projects to teach,
like kindergarten children, like a couple
of projects, not many.
Some of the kind of rules of this string
diagrammatic stuff in this quantum
information processing world.
Bob Cocker and his colleagues I think
there was one project by Dan Geeker in
Birmingham and maybe one by Bob himself,
or at least he was trying to get it off
the ground.
I don't remember.
But at least where it has been tried, I
think they found that children very
easily learn to use these kinds of
languages because it's just playing with
pictures.
They're kind of much more approachable
than this kind of scary symbolic language,
, which is it's a kind of fine language
if you're used to typing on a typewriter
or like writing by hand, where you write
in this linear way.
But if you go to a mathematics department
and look at the whiteboards or the
chalkboards there, most of the time you
see lots of pictures, diagrams and things.
.
And that's how people reason, typically.
And so a lot of what's been happening
with applied category theory is trying to
take using diagrams seriously as
mathematics and trying to say, okay, well,
, here's what we can do if we do take it
seriously.
We can sort of recapitulate some of these
things which people have found like
abstract or abstruse or difficult in
mathematics before and make them seem a
bit more easy to reason with.
Now.
That applies to abstract things like
stuff I've mentioned already, like
adjunctions, like the laws of adjunctions.
.
You can draw them with think string
diagrams.
I haven't shown it in my thesis.
But if you sort of Google around, you can
see adjunctions in a two category and
they end up being some kind of snaky
picture.
And sort of you get a sense of what's
going on there from these pictures, like
the flow of information in some sense.
And there's a similar thing with Monads.
The joke for functional programmers about
Monads is like, oh, you don't know what a
Monad is?
Well, it's just a monoid in the category
of endofunctors.
And I mean, that's true.
It's not just a joke.
It's true.
But the thing is, if you draw what a
monoid is, it's like a thing which like
one of these like you see on that picture
you've got this gauss thing, and then it'
's got a black dot, and you got one wire,
and then it has a black dot, and then two
wires come out of it.
And I said, this is like copying.
Well, a monoid is like that in the other
direction.
Like, you've got two things that go into
a dot and that come out with one thing.
So when people say monoid, they mean
something like they often mean something
like addition.
You've got two numbers that come together
and they produce one number.
We've got, like, multiplication.
You've got two numbers again that come
together and produce one number.
So it's like the opposite of copying in
some abstract sense, which takes one
thing and gives you two things.
This is something that takes two things
and gives you one thing.
And so you can just draw the diagrams
that define a monoid and say, okay, well,
what does this mean for endofunctors?
And you can sort of start to reason about
it a bit more approachably.
I mean, it's still quite abstract because
it is quite abstract, but it makes it
kind of less scary to use this kind of
language, I think.
Daniel: Awesome.
Yeah, there's so much psychology and
sociology in mathematics and just hearing
about yeah, on real chalkboards, people
branch and they flow and they circle
things and they put an X through
something.
It's like there's all these operations
that can't be copied with a typewriter.
And as our cyberphysical and social
niches develop and we have different
affordances, different metaphors,
different quantum reference frames for
working and being, it starts to make more
sense for having a natural language that
can express that.
Toby: Then I go on.
I said loads of stuff.
Daniel: It just makes me think of a
Turing tape where even if there is a
linear representation, it can still in
some other way characterize like a Lisp
program with nesting or hierarchical
model.
Even though, yes, there's like a
linearity but also there's a model.
So it's not that we can't represent
certain things with the bit streams or
anything like that.
It's just that that may be more like the
assembly language and that when we
actually want to do certain kinds of work,
, we may want to just move lightly and
semantically with a high level way to
think about math.
Toby: Yeah, totally.
It's kind of notable to me that recently
I've been giving talks for a while using
a computer, whether or not over zoom, but
it could be in person.
I have my PowerPoint slides or whatever,
but these days, if I give a talk, I just
use my digital tablet and I do everything,
, like all the slides by hand, and I draw
pictures.
And it's nice now that we've got
technology that is starting to be a bit
more human in that sense.
And I think this is like a kind of
mathematical technology which is like
that.
Although I think it's also notable that
it's still, in some sense, quite niche.
And I think I don't know, but the
impression I've got from talking to
people is that it's still the case that
some mathematicians think of this kind of
like mathematics as diagrams, as somehow
not quite like real mathematics, because
it's too much like play in some sense.
But I think that perspective is changing
and people are taking it seriously.
I mean, it is real work, and there's a
lot of hard problems and stuff actually
gets done.
But I think to me, it doesn't really
matter what, like, a handful of
mathematicians think.
It's just what's useful to people that
matters.
And so I hope that these tools continue
to develop and we can use them in all
sorts of different domains.
I don't know.
It's notable to me as well that human
vision is kind of like two and a bit
dimensional, really.
It's not really like three dimensional,
but you've got a bit of three
dimensionality.
And I've never really played much with,
like, three dimensional diagrams, but
maybe I will one day have some tools with
my Vision pro or less not pro thing or
whatever.
It allow me to do things even more
naturally, like actually plug together
some stuff in some abstract space.
Who knows?
Daniel: Yeah, the diagram being two
dimensional.
Or planar gives us this kind of classical
screen holographic screen.
That information can be written on that.
Then quantum cognitive agents can unfold
into the imaginary plane with the WIC
rotation.
But also the boundary, just like you said
earlier, can come in many shapes, many
dimensionalities.
So we could have a four dimensional
boundary artifact that still becomes
rotated into a higher dimension.
And that's not the framing or the
mathematics that most of us have learned
up to this point.
There's a really crystallized would be a
complementary way to say it, but codified
or fossilized sedimentary understanding
of math education, its role in broader
thinking and what we learn along the way,
and the progressions get reified with who
makes it through the pipeline.
So I think that's, like the unknown
unknowns here, the known unknowns.
We all know that we struggle to
understand this, but then that's the real
jumping off when it's not just us
adapting into a new regime of learning
and doing, but when there's composition
and construction within that regime.
In our last sections here, Dean or Ali,
another question.
Or what are you looking to bridge or gap
into the dot to?
Okay, Ali, please.
Ali: Well, yeah, actually, I've written
down a number of questions, but they may
be quite specific, and I think they're
perhaps best suited for the two
discussion.
But I wanted to thank Toby for I mean, I
literally had goosebumps the entire time.
.
So it was really fascinating and quite
enjoyable, and I learned a lot.
And I hope to… I also have some
additional questions in my mind.
I hope to get to some of them in the
second discussion.
So, yes, thank you again.
It was really great.
Toby: Thanks.
Daniel: Dean, with the penultimate
thoughts, what do you see us heading
into?
Dean: Yeah, well, if it's okay, I'd like
just to read a really brief piece of the
paper because I don't want to launch this
on Toby in the dot two, without giving
him a chance to think about this a bit.
Under seven four, you've got fundamental
theory, and you say future work connected
to this thesis need not only be in
applications, a number of purely
theoretical questions raise themselves
too.
And I love seven four one.
This one paragraph for me, I call it a
really have to slow down and enjoy the
moment today.
Toby, I don't know if you're a distance
runner, an endurance athlete of some kind,
, but your stamina has been phenomenal.
But this one paragraph to me would be
like a refreshment station where they
offer you a milkshake and a piece of
battered fish.
Like, it's yummy.
But you need to wait.
You have to pause and kind of go, I don't
know if I want to do that.
But it really ties in nicely with the
syntax stuff that Danny was talking about.
.
And I have a question at the end of it,
so I just want to read it, though.
The mathematics of belief.
So you basically said belief is
theoretical.
That's fantastic.
Is in large part about replacing definite
points with fuzzier distributions over
them.
Independent type theory, we replace
points with terms.
Independent terms are exactly points.
So a type of theory with belief should
somehow encompass fuzzy terms.
Just as we can replace points with
distributions, we can replace dependent
points with the dependent distributions.
However, the standard replacement, moving
from a category of functions to a
category of stochastic channels, obscures
some of the universal categorical
structure.
And underpins the rules of type theory,
this standard replacement also misses
something else.
While it does allow for fuzzy terms, it
omits a model of fuzzy types.
We might well want to express beliefs
about things whose identity we are not
quite sure.
And then you say in the next sentence,
there seems to be a couple of related
resolutions to this puzzle.
My question for you is this, and it's not
for today, it's maybe for next time.
It seems to me we have to grapple with
this idea of making fuzzy clear and
making fuzzy precise.
And you started speaking to that.
And my wonder of coming now with a strong,
, much stronger active inference set of
priors is there has to be something more
to this than just a gradient descent.
And I think you started to speak to that
in this section.
And so I'm kind of curious.
Do you think that this is a feature, the
fact that we can do this, we can do fuzzy
clear and fuzzy precise and not
necessarily see that as a contradiction,
but actually the way category theory kind
of gives us permission to examine that.
So, again, it doesn't have to be answered
today.
And maybe I'm misinterpreting what you
were trying to say there, so I'm open to
being redirected, but I just think that
this opens up a world of possibilities.
And when I first read it.
Toby: I.
Dean: Don'T know what Ally's Goosebumps
looked like, but I was just like, oh man,
I really want to ask you about this.
Toby: Yeah, the thing about fuzzy type.
Yeah, so I do got to start by saying I
agree that what some of this is seeking
is something like thinking clearly about
thinking fuzzily in some way is kind of
weird.
It's like having some certainty about
uncertainty.
But it's definitely the case that still
now I think a notion of fuzzy type theory
is not well developed, though I am aware
of people, various people having thought
about this and people thinking about it
at the moment.
And of course I've got my own ideas about
it, but it seems natural, right?
Like, we often think we know what a thing
like we can recognize a thing, but maybe
you're not quite sure and so you're not
sure if it's this or that or you see
somebody coming down the street towards
you and you kind of recognize them as
somebody you know or you used to know.
And then as they approach that, their
identity becomes a bit clearer, but you'
're not, you know, you weren't sure for a
while.
And I think there's nothing to say that
we shouldn't be able to in some sense,
like types are a kind of element of some
bigger space and so we should be able to
play all this math to it.
And it's kind of really about figuring
out what the rules are that makes the
kind of language of type theory kind of
align nicely with the language of
probability.
And it's a research effort, but I'm happy
to talk about it more next time.
I'm also happy to talk in any detail
about any of the actual specifics of the
stuff in the material, in the thesis or
whatever else in category theory you
might be interested in.
I'll probably be expert in everything, of
course, but I mean, I'm happy to try my
best, particularly if Ali, it sounded
like your questions were maybe of a more
technical nature, maybe not.
I don't know if I got the right sense of
what you were saying, but if they are, I'
'm happy to talk about the details of
that.
Ali: Thank you.
Toby: And also to review any of the stuff
to try to say, because you're right that
there's a lot of detail in the thesis
because you make a flame and you're
supposed to substantiate it and that
means you have to give a proof.
And sometimes the proof is quite
complicated.
But structurally, I want this to be
simple, or at least to have a simple
framework.
And so I would like to be able to clarify
some of that if there's time for that, or
if it comes to it.
Daniel: Yeah, that sounds amazing.
In two, we will return perhaps any
questions that people submit as a comment
on the video or as a message in the
category theory channel.
On our discord, we'll curate those
questions, we'll rewatch and digest, and
then we can begin with Ali asking some,
taking us on a little bit of a technical
journey.
And Toby, thanks again for the incredible
work.
It's defined our 2023 in many ways, so it'
's been a joy and we.
Toby: Look forward to next.
Thanks for plowing through.
There's also the stuff I think we talked
about before that we haven't really
touched on this time, and obviously I
didn't really touch on much in the thesis
about how do you actually fit in action
into this framework and how do you start
to talk about this multi agent stuff.
If there's time, we can talk about all of
that.
Daniel: Two of the pieces, just to share,
that gave us some of the most laughs were
first, we didn't get action and we're
like, it wasn't an anti climax, it was a
climax of its own.
And and then also we had had so many
discussions over the months of time and
the treatment of time backwards and
forwards, ringing the bell, unringing the
bell, all of these different concepts.
And then in your limitations, you said we
really have to work on getting a
dynamical treatment.
Toby: Oh, yeah.
But I actually think that depending on
what you care about, it may not be too
hard.
So that's fine.
Daniel: But even that you would say it
that way, just having dealt with time and
then to be like, well, I thought that's
what dynamical modeling was, involving
time.
Toby: No, you're right.
You're totally right there.
So all I meant at that point was the kind
of statistical framework that I've been
working with until then.
It just seems you have a prior and a way
of generating predictions, but there's
nothing to say that the prior has any
data about how stuff actually evolves in
time or the predictions have any data
about how the Sense data evolves in time.
.
It's just like I believe that there's
this on the screen and that makes there
be this stuff coming to my eye and that's
it.
It's just like a snapshot.
And so when you want to include time
evolution in those beliefs, things become
a bit more complicated.
Awesome.
Daniel: Well, thank you again, Toby.
We'll see you in a week and a day.
Toby: It's been a pleasure.
Thank you for having me.
Bye.
Ali: Thank you so much.
Toby: Bye.